creo que en este caso cuando tenemos un
proceso de golpe estado quedarían dos
opciones uno puede utilizar la fuerza y
tratar de a largo plazo hacer que la que
las platas sociales se aplaquen o por el
otro lado tratar de analizar las
demandas que se plantean y aceptarlas o
reformular las acorde a los intereses de
uno lo dijo muy bien en el vídeo 53 años
de régimen militar no es la transición
lo que está en juego sino es el cambio
del sistema político contundente en
sudán en este momento y es que este país
ha estado dirigido casi de manera
ininterrumpida por los militares desde
su independencia hace 65 años como lo
discutíamos pero el pueblo parece
decidido a exigir un gobierno civil
puede esto degenerar en un conflicto
mayor
creo que en este contexto ha habido una
gran activación de la sociedad civil en
la región antes desde túnez egipto y
libia incluso a pesar de que están en
conflicto incluyendo un sudán eso se
entienden de que si no se movilizan o no
toman las calles es muy probable que
pierdan esa potencialidad de revolución
ahora bien la labor abarca los cálculos
del régimen militar van a estar en
tratar de mantenernos a un nivel de
violencia lo suficientemente aceptable
para no perder las calles pero al mismo
tiempo tratar de solventar sus demandas
dado que después de tanto tiempo en el
poder probablemente no quieran perder el
control del proceso señor benítez
resistirán los militares no sólo a la
presión de la calle sino también al
corte de ayudas desde eeuu y el banco
mundial
es interesante esta pregunta a la
comunidad internacional porque cuando
uno analiza los potenciales aliados por
lo menos a nivel regional del régimen de
columnas de los militares de sudán
podemos encontrar que desde egipto
incluso arabia saudita han tenido
vinculaciones sabemos que el gobierno de
ciudadana ha tenido mercenarios operando
en gm y esto ha generado ciertos
beneficios por parte de arabia saudita
entendemos que algo importante en sudán
es que se mantenga una estabilidad al
menos a nivel internacional y durante
mucho tiempo esta estabilidad incluso
fue garantizada a pesar de la falta de
calidad democrática en el país desde
luego que la comunitat nacional debe
oponerse incluso a la unión africana
también tiene una política en contra del
golpe de estado pero es una pelea de
resistencia a la largada ver a los
militares cómo pueden mantenerse en el
poder y tratar de controlar el proceso
de transición
eventualmente aceptar las demandas de la
sociedad civil señor manitas y
finalmente quedan esperanzas por la
llegada de un gobierno civil que era una
de las principales aspiraciones del
pueblo tras la caída de omar al bachir
en opinión creo que la llegada de un
gobierno civil más sería la garantía de
un cambio sustancial en sudán desde su
independencia a la construcción del
sistema político ha estado basado en la
concentración del poder esta
concentración del poder se fue
aunando en distintos grupos o élites en
este caso hablamos de los militares creo
que lo importante o la esperanza que
suceden ahora es que con la presencia de
civiles o incluso con la presión en los
militares el cambio de este proceso de
transición devengan un cambio sustancial
y profundo de la forma de
representatividad en el país